first of all good looking
it's not just about like being
universally good looking everyone's got
their thing sometimes it's about just
having a certain what is it je ne sais
quoi you got something going on you got
some sort of fire right
also good looking comes with like how
you carry yourself as a guy i think it's
super important the way you carry
yourself the way you walk into a room
what's super attractive oftentimes about
men is men who don't give a [ __ ]
about how you feel about them
initially right like they're not worried
about like oh i need to dress like this
that a woman's gonna like it or i need
to do this so they're just them they're
very comfortable in their own skin so
they're wearing what they're wearing
their hair looks the way it looks maybe
their sandals are a little busted up
whatever it is they're totally cool with
who they are they've got a presence when
they walk in that's just like hey
take it or leave it you know that's very
very attractive